a radical abortion group declaring open
season on pro-lifers after a series of
attacks across the country at least 13
pro-life centers have been targets of
arson or vandalism and the group is
promising more terror could be on the
way saying in a letter quote it's open
season and we know where your operations
are everyone with the urge to paint to
burn to cut to jam now is the time go
forth and manifest the things you wish
to see
speaker nancy pelosi asked to condemn
the new threat of violence today but she
said this instead
a woman has a right to choose to live up
to her responsibility it's up to her
her
doctor her family her husband her her
significant other and her god
uh this talk of politicizing all of this
i think
is something uniquely american and not
right
and after a man was indicted for trying
to assassinate supreme court justice
brett kavanaugh president biden has
still yet to sign a bill giving security
to members of the high court they say
it's technical and whatever well it
should get signed but should get signed
right away because the protesters are
still out there in the first block jesse
we talked about gascon not following
through with the enforcement of the law
and
merit garland is the attorney general of
the united states one he's not arrested
one person who is breaking the law
who's protesting outside of justice's
home
they're 15 minutes away it wouldn't be
hard to do and haven't said anything
about this but if it was
abortion clinics do you imagine that it
would be different what you don't
understand dana is that left-wing
violence is just an idea remember antifa
just an idea right-wing violence
greatest threat to national security
ever left-wing violence that's just an
idea and where's the fbi
i mean someone sneezes
at a militia group and like 15 fbi
members
take off their
jackets with fbi and then arrest
everybody have they infiltrated jane's
addiction
are they entrapping any of these radical
activists absolutely not there's not
even a suspect there hasn't even been a
single arrest whatever happened to
silence is violence
remember you have to condemn white
supremacy unless you if you don't you're
complicit
they've asked joe they've asked nancy
remember how many times they asked
donald trump to condemn racism who did
it like 50's like who do you want me to
condem what do you want me to do it
she got a meatball down the middle of
the plate and she pivoted and didn't
condemn so she's giving license to this
stuff and where is the leak
investigation
how hard is that you round up the clerks
and you waterboard them
jesse you take their phones and you
waterboard them theoretically you
waterboard their brains with tough
questions everybody knows i'm kidding
this is what's going to happen next week
the
supreme court court's going to release
this opinion and they're probably going
to be gone by then they'll probably be
in their houses in maine on the coast or
at some lake house in minnesota because
once this comes down
there is going to be action
judge when you hear nancy pelosi pivot
away and just say but a woman has a
right to choose i mean in some ways it's
like well okay the the ruling would send
the decisions back to the states where
the states could decide so you could
have the legislative fight there yeah or
you could have violence at all these
places well they don't truly believe in
democracy because true democracy is if
the issue of choice abortion whatever
you want to call it is delivered to each
state where everybody gets to vote so
they don't believe in true democracy
although every day they're out there
fighting because everything we do is a
threat to democracy but the pivoting
in answer to the question a woman has
the right to choose is like jen saki's
saying the president thinks people have
a right to protest this is what i was
talking about in the last block
this is if you step back and look at it
this is a government that picks and
chooses what laws they want to enforce
and what laws they want to ignore and as
a result of that we've got an attempted
murder of the united states supreme
court justice we've got all kinds of
people violating title 18 1507 not being
arrested we've got we finally get a law
passed it's on biden's status to protect
the supreme court justices and the
reason that 22 out of 27 democrats
wouldn't sign the bill that simply calls
for protecting supreme court justices is
they didn't move fast enough on gun
control so we don't care about their
lives and all 22 of the 27 of them they
asked for extra security for themselves
as if they're more important than a
supreme court justice who's there for
life the democrats are the party of
chaos anarchy violence and intolerance
they also said that they wanted federal
judges also to get that protection the
republicans said okay so let's write
another bill we can talk about that
they're not against that what harold
what is going on at the justice
department of the united states
probably a lot and um i agree with
everything that's been said i disagree
it's not a democrat issue but i do i do
democrats are not well let me just
finish my point
republicans and democrats we we have a
virus of extremism in the country and
that extremism manifests itself with
everyone believing that violence is okay
if it's in your in your in pursuit of a
goal that you want it has manifested
itself in this cancel culture
conversation we all like language that
we like
but if it's language we don't like we
want to cancel it and it goes on both
sides of the aisle in that regard
judge you're right most governments uh
and whomever is elected as president
they prioritize the laws that they want
they want to not enforce what they're
going to to go about
really pursuing and we can all have
disagreements about that the one thing
about when governments do that or
governor or president or mayor does it
is we we can unelect them i think i
think every democrat and i've said this
any democrat that does not condemn this
violence does not condemn what's going
on outside of justices of the supreme
court's homes
in real ways are not fit to be in
positions of leadership republicans who
do the same who don't condemn violence
when it's against whether it's
republican or democrat we're undermining
our democracy when we don't do this we
the thing that happened in virginia
last year in the governor's race there
were a number of people that came out
parents that came out and protested at
school board meetings which i thought
was fine but when you begin to threaten
elected officials i have a real problem
with that most people should be arrested
the way you the way you change a policy
of public policies you unelected people
in office the people of virginia when
elected the governor if they want it in
the commonwealth of region that's what
we should do
go ahead i just look look i think what's
happening justin permanent i agree with
you dana if if
it's we sometimes invoke race a little
too much here and i i don't i don't like
the race i'm talking about racial we
talked about racism
we're talking about party we're talking
about the fact that the democratic party
with blm burning down police precincts
and neighborhoods in 2020 said nothing
until after the republican national
convention they waited for months nobody
said boo okay and now we've got the
people who are who are nancy pelosi joe
biden they're not criticizing the people
in front of the supreme court justices
who should be charged and indicted for
uh title 18 1507. we're not talking
about race here we're talking about the
law that is being violated that they are
not enforcing because of their let me
get a problem
because in the first block you talked
about the government not holding up its
end of the contract and by the justice
department not actually enforcing any of
these laws you have to wonder like who's
who's going to stand up for the people
well first of all we have to address the
real offensive thing that was said at
this table it's called jane's revenge
jesse not jane's addiction a great band
from the 90s one of the greatest all
rock paper scissors did i really say
that you did
and it was disgusting all right so
there's an interesting there is an
interesting theme here if you look at
merrick garland and you look at pelosi
and then you look at the media coverage
of the attempted assassination of
kavanaugh
i have four examples generally you only
need three examples for a trend
okay but i have four examples four this
is kind of exciting to me so one you
have attacks on pro-life offices right
then you have the letter uh that was
labeling parents as domestic terrorists
then you have there's no mercy being
shown for the january six protesters
many of whom have never agitated in
their lives right okay that's three
number four voting not to protect uh
scotus while protecting themselves so
that's four examples they all have
something in common that is
i think the word is the two words is
open season it it's as though the media
should be distributing hunting licenses
and bright orange vests to the excited
hunters aching to get that you know bag
their first concerned parent all of
these people are tangentially or
somewhat related to the right
republicanism so that's kind of what i
think that's what we're all getting at
here is like we're looking at this we're
going
is it open season on anybody and purely
by uh by just connection so you have
some real like when harold talks about
radicals you know we do have radicals
they have radicals but now
it's being the broad brush we're all bad
and so what happens is merrick garland
ignores it pelosi ignores it the media
ignores it because they're kind of imp
it's being implied that it's okay to go
hunting
and
we're
we're seeing people getting hunted in
various forms and you can't deny it if
it's not being stopped
the last thing i would point out is
there are these 13 attacks have been
against pregnancy centers you know what
happens at a pregnancy center where they
help a woman uh who is maybe maybe she's
going to be a single mom maybe she wants
to keep her baby or maybe she wants to
get her baby up for adoption but she
needs help they do all sorts of things
they help with counseling they help with
finances or like helping them get the
equipment that they'll need in order to
do that these are the places that are
being attacked so think about that too
jane hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now